all right before we get started this is
kind of becoming a mandalorian tradition
i want to thank the sponsor of this
video this video is brought to you by
vincero
vincero watches or timepieces as i like
to call them offer a stylish
and modern look and feel without
breaking your bank
ventero's flipping the script hawk style
when it comes to style and affordability
they have a quality build and
feel to them so you feel sharp as well
as look sharp like what's the point of
dressing sharp if you don't feel it
that's my mod and what i know for
certain is a good timepiece is
that accents among your attire that just
makes all the difference and once again
with the season of giving being
upon us santa john's has come through
now through december 2nd they're having
their black friday cyber monday week
sale
click the link in the description save
up to 25 off your order as well as free
shipping watches
wallets sunglasses all of it the
discounts applied automatically upon
checkout as long as you click my link in
the description because that
is my link it is special remember this
deal is only going on now through
december 2nd so there is a limited time
so click the link below get your stylish
timepiece on and thank you once again to
vincero for sponsoring this video
i do appreciate it all right now what
not gonna lie
it's a really good episode an episode
that starts right out too i mean spoiler
alert for this episode because i have to
talk about spoilers
i'm going to talk about the episode but
yeah the episode was called the jedi
dave filoni directed the episode so
people were like
ahsoka's going to be in this one also
he's looking for ahsoka
there's a clue but i thought we were
gonna have to wait halfway through this
episode was
like oh noah soca halfway through now
here's a suck
no those two lightsabers pop out just
and there's a fight and she's just
slaughtering this army and there's this
town run by a couple of douche
bags that torture people and michael
bean
surprised to see him wearing clone
wars-esque army look at the armories
wearing it was very
anakin early clone wars and this is the
classic story of
mando's looking for ahsoka this town
wants to hire someone to kill a sukkah
so like hey you want to go kill her he's
like
i will go find her sure
he's very careful with his wording he
never actually promised
to kill her something you notice you're
like oh
he's doing that thing where's like well
technically i didn't say so point is he
finds ahsoka and ahsoka's like
oh hey it's a baby yoda i mean i i knew
one like him and his name was yoda
just like him which really shows the
power of wording i mean jedi
they've been referenced yes it's that
thread of like oh this isn't a reference
this is a direct like hey i knew one
like him and his name was yoda i always
look for moments like that moments that
are the difference between a reference
and a full-on
naming a named character and they get a
lot of backstory with baby yoda whose
name isn't baby yoda's like goku or
something
grogu i'm gonna call him goku or just a
baby yoda
what can i say old habits die hard and
all that he has a name now and there's a
whole backstory with him and he was this
young
jedi in the jedi order and then the jedi
order fell and he was hidden away
because yoda was like hey that's mine
and yaddle's
child you know it so he's been hiding
his powers which is funny because he
played
those force powers a bit fast and loose
around mando but it does illustrate that
he does feel comfortable around mandela
so yeah we get his name we get his
backstory we
kind of get the whole thing which i like
a little bit of mystery with baby odor
i've liked being able to be like oh
who is he where does he come from and
well now we know so it gave us answers
but it did take away from a little bit
of that but it does
look like they're expanding this
universe
a lot more i'll get into it point is
she's like he's very afraid which you
get is
he knows that the jedi were slaughtered
for being jedi
so yeah he's like i'm kind of freaked
out i don't want to show my powers which
it does illustrate he's aware of what
mando says to him and he knows what he's
saying and you know he's
he's older than he looks to us he's baby
yoda and he's really more like well he's
young yoda but he understands things
he understands what mando says he
understands that that lady's eggs were
all she had i make jokes
i really don't give a it's just fun
to joke about i say that because there
were people who
genuinely gave a but yeah with that
fear of silk is like no
i can't train him mando's like why and
she's like i've seen what fear does
to a fully trained jedi to the best of
us and you feel that line that lie is a
powerful thing and
it's directly that's what that's what
clone wars did for me the best thing
that happened to the star wars prequels
for me
was the clone wars animation because it
did it really fleshed it out you feel
like oh yeah anakin skywalker he is the
greatest and he still fell to the dark
side so yeah she's like i can't train
him because
darth vader and where have you been
yeah amanda do you ever know about that
really
powerful right hand of the emperor that
was
yeah you heard the stories right yeah
that was that was my master
that would have been a conversation so
she's like look i i'm not gonna train
him plus you're like a father figure to
him anyways so he should just stay with
you which i figured that was gonna
happen i mean
the whole implication was that he's
gonna drop this kid off
with the jedi which still might happen
but
the mandalorian is the dynamic between
baby yoda goku and mando like that
dynamic is the show if baby yoda goes
away it's
really not the show anymore but they go
back to the town to liberate the town
square off against the douchebags who
have the town under their boot heel
which is ahsoka going against the lady
with the spear
that spear made out of the same metal as
mando's armor which deflects lightsabers
and mando
having this very western good the bad
the ugly kind of stand off against
michael bean's character and he just
takes it in the chest he's
he's done and it's yeah soca versus this
lady which i mean it looks like i mean
she has a spear and his two lightsabers
so it looks like it's like oh this
might be like darth maul versus obi-wan
and qui-gon it's not like that
but very compelling thing happens ahsoka
gets her she's like where's your boss
and you're thinking yeah where's moff
gideon where's grand admiral thrawn
unexpected she tells amanda like look
take baby yoda go to this place and put
him on this altar and
he'll send i don't know four psychic
shock waves out there and
possibly sense or call other jedi there
aren't many jedi left out there but i
guess there are jedi which i've thought
of
ever since you know this ahsoka and cal
i'm like well cal
might still be out there ahsoka now we
know he's out there yoda really got it
wrong on that one didn't he
yeah when god am i
the last of the jedi will you be what he
really meant was
in terms of this story not the last
jedi there are more out there but it has
nothing to do with you
because it's the extended
universe so yeah there there are others
out there
just sat the fight out i guess with the
empire the other jedi are just hiding
out in their hookah bar like yeah well
you know we've done our bid for king and
country so it looks like ahsoka tano is
on the hunt for grand admiral
thrawn they're saying it is possible
that the batch of cumber
could play grand admiral thrawn i i just
thought that was never happening ever
which really shows the show
mandalorian for what it is it really is
this experiment this litmus test this
possible springboard into bringing more
live-action star wars shows but they
wanted to see how mandalorian was
received possibly more don't know but it
looks like
an ahsoka live-action spin-off
definitely might be in the cards
plus let's be real ahsoka's worth her
own
series you know like she should have her
own series and that's the thing i was
really looking for looking at in this
episode is like how did they do with
silke how was ahsoka represented i think
ahsoka they
did it really well i mean dave filoni i
guess directed this episode that helps
but you know it's in the back of your
mind you're like i hope they do
silica well we'll see how it goes she's
a great character and i thought rosario
dawson did a good job bringing her to
life it's the first live-action ahsoka
that we've gotten which means ahsoka and
luke
they're around doing jedi-ish things at
the same time and
they could cross paths not gonna lie
the common denominator being disney
between lucasfilm and the mcu
i wouldn't hate seeing sebastian stan
playing
live-action young luke skywalker who
crosses paths with the socatano and it
could just be a fan moment like oh
that'd be cool but it might not happen
maybe it's just wishful thinking but in
terms of the connecting the dots
you don't have to connect too many dots
for that to be a logical thing
the empire's fallen luke's going to
start building his jedi training academy
that i imagine would get ahsoka's
attention the name
skywalker on that thing definitely will
she'll be like
luke who now i gotta meet him like what
would she do be like
skywalker huh well that is a little out
of the way i'm going this way and you
know
what can you say man time is money so
let's not waste both
i imagine she would make time to be like
i'm gonna pop my head in there and
see what that is see what's going on
also for luke skywalker i think that
could be a good moment because he never
really knew his parents
i mean the fact that anakin skywalker's
force ghost was
seen at the end of return of the jedi
the implication is well
anakin could have come to luke but in
the sequel trilogy we never really
got the impression that that ever
happened but
fan fiction what can you say but in
return of the jedi you feel
the hurt in luke's voice he never knew
his mother i have no memory of my mother
never knew his mother never really got
time with his father but now there's
this
jedi out there who knew both
very well so i don't crave an adventure
i don't need it to be exciting i just
think that would be good for luke to
have ahsoka come to him sit down and she
could be like
here's what your parents were like i
knew them very well and they were
awesome people she's really the link to
luke's past that i think
luke deserves and has probably been
searching for for a while i mean the
original trilogy
every time someone mentioned his father
and maybe oh someone knew his father
he perked up he was like they knew my
father i told you to forget it oh okay i
guess i'll stop
asking questions about my past also now
that i'm thinking about it i don't know
if ahsoka knows that anakin died good
she might be carrying the false reality
on her shoulders that
her mentor her master became a monster
and just blew up in the death star and
died a monster so she meets up with luke
luke could also be like thanks for
telling me about my dad
also um he turned good and restored
balance he died the jedi you knew so
that could be good for both of them and
there are so many reasons to have luke
and ahsoka meet up
in a world in a universe where they're
alive and doing things at the same time
i think they can both really benefit
from a conversation with each other but
we'll see might just be wishful thinking
but yeah all in all i thought this was a
really good episode i thought rosario
dawson was great as ahsoka it was great
to see ahsoka and it was great to see
ahsoka
done well an important thing is you feel
the past she doesn't feel like a
different character you do feel like
this
is the live-action version the same
character as the animated ahsoka it's
it's all the same character sometimes
that happens that's why i bring it up
where it's like oh you have the animated
version and the live action version but
they don't feel the same
i thought they did a good job at making
ahsoka feel like ahsoka all right so the
mandalorian season 2 episode 5
titled the jedi have you seen it what
did you think about it did you like
seeing ahsoka do you think they did
ahsoka justice did you like seeing
rosario dawson
as ahsoka oh that just felt kind of like
a tongue twister anyhow whatever you
think comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]
you